listen i have my younger son who's
younger than my daughter uh
once came up to me and i did a sad truth
clip on it on my channel
where he saw something i can't remember
the exact details but it was something
like
the future is female male toxicity
toxic masculinity and he was sitting
with me watching and he kind of looked
at me and i don't remember his exact
words but he said something like
daddy are are boys really bad it was
really with the innocence of a young
child
and imagine that you are inculcating
to half the world's population known as
boys
this kind of pathological stage right
you're pathologizing masculinity it's
grotesque
we could we could be feminist in the
truest sense of the term and the
christina huff summer sense of the word
without
being pathologizing half of the world
called boys
what do you think it will take truly to
get us past this
that that seems to be the next step of
this conversation okay we
we talked about it for a while we
understand it now the masses
see a problem but but what is the thing
beyond just the courage part i mean what
what would be a societal way
to actually put some of this stuff
behind us
so certainly having sort of a
cataclysmic
you know savior trump come along but
the reality is trump is only is going to
be out either in a few months or in a
few years
so you can't just rely on trump because
he ended critical race theory
then the problem that idea pathogen is
going to go away forever but you
certainly need
something i thought he's never i thought
he's never going to step down and he's
going to be president until 2064 or
something i could have
i thought exactly exactly so so
certainly having someone who was able to
come from the outside
and redress many of these things is
great but i truly think it's a long
game you know war there has to be
involvement for every so i'll give you
an example my
my uh one of my children her her science
teacher
has a blm sign as an avatar so i could
do one of two things at that point i
could say well
forget it or i could write politely
right without being too bombastic
without
engaging all sorts of gadisms you know
cutting satire
i could write to her politely and say
you know is it appropriate
for a science teacher who is educating
my young child
to espouse a particular position what if
we don't agree with this position right
so i can at that point i have a
bifurcation i can either get
involved or not get involved that has to
happen
300 million times a day in every
interaction and every exchange
if that happens the wall of [ __ ]
will collapse quickly
if it doesn't it will be a long
drawn-out needless war
so this is why i implore people get
engaged your voice matters
it's not only up for to dave rubin to
change the course of culture
each of you is important obviously i
have to ask you
did you ask the teacher to do anything i
know you i know we all pick our spots we
pick our fights what would you do
i haven't i haven't yet because you know
my wife was worried that i might engage
in some sort of cutting
positions that might not be modulated
well enough and that might cause sort of
a retribution
so in that particular case i've yet to
do it but i can tell you that my
daughter has often come up to me and
said
daddy the blm is still up so i think
she's kind of almost egging me
to to get involved and in a sense look
by
my children being around me and seeing
the positions that i take
that's one of the ways by which i fight
right so if i do that and you do that
with your children he does that with
this
but by the way the the the cretans are
always trying to introduce the idea
pathogens
ever so earlier so it starts with the
universities then we go to the high
schools
then we go to the elementary because the
best time to reach a mind to make it as
malleable as you can
is when it doesn't have yet the
cognitive defenses to protect itself
against the idea pathogens
but by the way she's the one who made
the joke uh yesterday she was eating
something during kippur
and she said well don't worry daddy i
self-identify as
as right so this little child who has
heard my satire was able to construct
that satirical moment i i was told a
story by a friend of mine who has
a five-year-old that in you know the
school year just started
and that one of the parents sent around
a note
uh to the to the other parents in the
class that the boy
biological boy uh he's a boy at home
but wants to be a girl at school and
they so they want everyone to refer to
him as whatever the
the girl name is the female name at
school but then he goes home and he's a
boy again
and again without this is not mocking
trans people or anything like that but
it's sort of the way it all spills over
so that that everyone else has to behave
the way
you want them to behave but also could
this possibly have come from the
five-year-old i want to be a girl at
school but a boy at home like
it doesn't really sound like that no and
listen i have my younger son who's
younger than my daughter
uh once came up to me and i did a sad
truth clip on it on my channel
where he saw something i can't remember
the exact details but it was something
like
the future is female male toxicity
toxic masculinity and he was sitting
with me watching and he kind of looked
at me and i don't remember his exact
words but he said something like
daddy are are boys really bad it was
really with the innocence of a young
child
and imagine that you are inculcating
to half the world's population known as
boys
this kind of pathological stage right
you're pathologizing masculinity it's
grotesque
we could we could be feminist in the
truest sense of the term and the
christina hof summer sense of the word
without being
pathologizing half of the world called
boys
yeah i know jordan wrote a blurb jordan
peterson wrote a blurb for the book
um that's really what he was hitting on
more than anything else right i mean he
was trying to well i can't say more than
anything else but
in conjunction with many other big
things that
that you can't say to all these boys
you're inherently evil
and now he's been gone for a year and a
half and i think a lot of people
are lost without that yeah and i i gotta
say
since he is a common friend when i wrote
to jordan it was
to for to get him the to get from him
the endorsement for the book it was
literally at the worst possible time
when he was going through all his stuff
and he writes right back to me and says
you are literally the first person i'm
responding to
you know since opening my laptop this is
the kind of
friendship that matters right jordan and
i can disagree on some things we
disagree on young
we disagree on but even if we disagree
on points a and b
when it comes to going into the trenches
together you want to have guys who have
your back and at his
lowest moment he was willing to take
time so love the guy
dad are you telling me that academic
people could have different beliefs come
to different conclusions
and not try to get each other fired or
kicked out of the university or out of
all the social clubs
incredible isn't it who knew it it's
just bizarre
uh what else can can the average person
do i mean
that that to me is where this all comes
together the average guy you're at i
mean
because what it always comes down to
also is the person going forget the
tenured part that you talked about it
whatever and that certain people's
makeup isn't to be combative
but just the person who's going you know
i'm just at whatever my job is you know
i'm a decent hard-working person
i've got kids i've got all these other
responsibilities and for me to
to do that little jump even though i
think most people agree with you most
people heard what you said and they go
well if 300
million people all did it once we really
could change something overnight
but in their own life they just can't do
it are there any other tricks
because this is the question i get all
the time yeah yeah i mean i
so in chapter eight the last chapter i
do have a set of prescriptions like
the chapter's called call to action so
i'll give you a few one of them
does address the fact that you said oh
some of them are not combative the
reality is
you can't have your values and
principles murdered and raped
without ever being combative if i'm
walking down the street with my wife
and three guys come to gang rape her i
can't say
sorry sorry sweetie i'm not combative so
good luck
right so i i have to and then one of the
prescriptions i have is
activate your inner honey badger now the
reason why again i use this
animal comparison because honey badgers
don't give an
f right honey badgers you can have a
a pride of lines six lines you could go
on on youtube and see those clips
you can have six lines approach a honey
honey badger is the size of
emma may she rest in peace a small a
small dog
and the response will be so ferocious
that the six six lions will look at each
other and go what the hell i don't want
part of this right
so you can't really fight in a war in
this case a war of ideas
without ever triggering your ire without
ever being indignant
so you can't be passive you can't be
castrated so
unfortunately you have to at once once
in a while be quebec so activate your
inner honey badger
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about academia
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our academia playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell